grazie grazie a tutti grazie ringraziamo
voi per questo caloroso benvenuto il
tadic se tutto in particolare nei loro
organizzatori a ringraziare la bellezza
loro che devono ringraziarlo richiamo
qua non ci pagano grazie quindi se vi
erano mangiato andare al bagno gabeca
ragazzi dettagli però magari ne parliamo
questa era un'occasione anche per
prendere tempo e se dobbiamo stare 15
minuti come tutti gli altri ha detto
questo siccome si è probabilmente di
accettare una cosa del genere che
accettavano i 15 minuti cioè noi
facciamo video da due minuti kakà teen
ed altri mercatini adesso ori da 15
secondi
15 15 min un quarto d'ora si ha idea di
quanto è un quarto d'ora si lo so se tu
prendi un ora è la tv di poco per qua 44
parti uguali non ci sono e sono tanti
sono qua prendi una di queste è come far
natura quello lo so cosa è un quarto
d'ora concedendo terminare lo so
com'è e come uno a cui non frega nulla
di calcio e guarda una partita di serie
b lo so è come uno che ci capisce niente
di musica guarda un concerto jazz come
un non gay al teatro dell'opera no
guarda quello che posso garantire che
anche a mettere all'opera finito col
latte alle ginocchia completamente di
infissi si no ma ci sono fede di cose
proprio se si va se sapessero in giro
mirati e rebbero dall'albo dei gay c'è
un albo dei sì sì sì come si chiama alba
parietti
[Risate]
quali sarebbero queste cose per esempio
io però non che non si sappia troppo in
giro io per esempio mi confondo 33 tutti
ma tra lady gaga beyoncé shakira che
c'entra la febbre io mi confondo con vin
diesel e the rock questo non vuol dire
che non sia etero chi sono vin diesel e
the rock è che appunto comunque vediamo
non sono tipo tipo fai conto bud spencer
e terence hill ha pero pelati a
possiamo attimo tornare al focus cosa
sono vorrei che la gente credesse che
stiamo cercando di te così a casa per
prendere tempo noi stiamo prendendo
tempo fabris no ma come non anzi
parliamo lentamente
almeno e quindi sale sapore io vorrei
che vorrei che la gente percepisce in
cui un po più
alta noi qualcosa da dire ce l'abbiamo
ma vogliamo dire questa cosa e sei gay
lo
voglio dire che fosse proprio
impietosire non fa che impietosire entra
io dico che quando di questo nuovo piano
prima mi insultano la mamma e poi mi the
fall non voglio dire che sono che ha
voglia di un'altra cosa è quello che
voglio dire che noi che siamo napoletani
no non è che siamo la pole edizioni
figli di napoletani spiega qua
fraintendono poi niente di male a noi
che siamo vegetariani basse mi fai
parlare basta prezioso dove parli sopra
non riesco a dire volevo finire ecco noi
non volevamo far ridere nessuno va bene
non ammorbare la gente con queste cose
che vuole fare uno dei due monologhi
noiosa che monologo noioso
chiamato no io voglio spiegare queste
persone che come nascono le nostre idee
siamo pagliacci sono io ma che fai a
cera pari a generare idee noi siamo
anche ci hanno chiamati perché siamo
persone proveniente da noi andiamo come
abbiamo qualcosa da dire è bene noi
vogliamo raccontarvi
praticamente noi non è che siamo
semplicemente di roma come si può forse
vincere dall'accento non prettamente
bergamasco e siamo di roma nord ma
queste cose che non sa spiegarsi
all'altro manovra roma nord e la nord è
come simona come una piccola città
l'intera città un quartiere come un
pensiero una piccola milano all'interno
di roma milan ce ne sono di chi ha letto
per la ragione
c'è questa piccola milano all'interno di
roma no solo che comunque non è come la
minaccia
in questa piccola milano all'interno di
roma gli autobus non arrivano c'è
monnezza ovunque c'è traffico non c'è
parcheggi non funziona niente agente
bestemmia per strada si insultano e in
questa piccola milano e che non funziona
e ci sono questi esseri umani ad essere
esseri umani adesso mi pare un po
effettivamente di un anno non hanno
molto esseri siliconati e questi esseri
siliconati praticamente passano una
parte del tempo a non fare nulla e poi
tutto il restante del tempo insomma si
riposano giustamente non si sa come
questi signori a nel conto in banca che
più alto del pil della norvegia la
norvegia della di marzo viene di una
qualsiasi nazione europea e quindi
capite che non sia l'italia ovviamente e
quindi capite bene che ogni volta che
noi diciamo veniamo da roma nord la
gente ci guarda un quel sorriso sornione
un po un po da po da complice no che
eccede già ecco un altro riccone ma si
sta sta storia della chiesa però all
icona riccone senza h grande e ricco
capito e voglio la spiegasse persone che
noi siamo dei poveracci che ci abbiamo
avuto mai un euro ma manca una lira
quando c'era la lira cioè che quando
loro avevano la paghetta noi non
vedevamo mai un soldo quando loro
c'erano una barca noi c'eravamo manco un
triciclo due no tutto ricordo quando
loro andavano alle maldive al mare ne
andavamo al mare a ostia la nonna
colmare marrone no non è che devi di
tutto no no no no la poveretta pace
all'anima sua era una santa donna però
quel mare dalle gambe dal gange scusa e
voi dovete sapere che il nostro primo
video è stata rondo ricordi nasce non
con l'intento di fare visualizzazione di
diventare famosi di diventare insomma
virali ecco quello era è un grido
d'aiuto ragazzo noi non è che volevamo
raccontare la storiella di due ragazzi
che erano rimasti a roma agos che ce ne
frega da raccontare storie a noi noi
volevamo far vedere che effettivamente
noi due stavamo a roma senza fare niente
volevamo essere invitato in vacanza sia
qualcuno deve servire secondo me siamo
riusciti nel nostro intento è
conveniente per niente lotti commentava
rideva se condividerà
grandi che sto morendo e sono sicuro che
sapesse questi infami che sono infami
commentavano dal loro yacht a porto
cervo è data dalla loro jacuzzi sulle
dolomiti con loro banca sulle maldive la
loro sdraia torvaianica
che non ci sono mai stato trovato un
altro vaiani o con la j pop regia drive
bisognerebbe fa schifo
in sostanza così nascono i nostri video
ne abbiamo grandi eroi perché perché è
ovvio funzionavano perché psicologia
spicciola cioè c'è praticamente la gente
vedendo noi questi due due disgraziati a
roma e facevano la colla a casa
anche se stavano su una sdraio a
torvaianica si sentivano dei piccoli
gianluca vacca incerta carola dicono
avete c'è chi è più disperato di me e
così nasce il progetto le coliche
praticamente monetizzare sulle nostre
nefandezze le nostre disgrazie
quotidiane e tra le è stato il nostro
blu ray certo certo certo che abbiamo in
alto abbiamo infilato anche il tema il
tema che è certo a forza risiamo
giustificate stare qua e la mente così
nascono e vero c'era noi che ne so
stavamo appunto a roma
video estate a roma facile no stavamo
che ne so e ci faceva schifo la musica
indie e non ne potevamo più sotto il
sole di riccione via parodia del
giornalista trovar altro uomo fastidiosa
l'efficienza di milano rispetto a roma è
armata roma verso milano ci faceva
schifo al mare di ostia ma stiamo
accedere a quello che ci hanno pagato
era una marchetta 3 avrà un mare di
ostia fa schifo comunque senza lamentare
di tumi chiara e questa è una cosa bella
certo ci hanno cominciato pure a pagare
se ci pagavano per lamentarci certo
ricordi tempo fa qualche anno fa si
chiama la universal strada chissà cosa
si fa guardate le dovete
non dovreste venire a hollywood in un
hotel a cinque stelle che c'era mai
stata una vera un set di jurassic park
con i dinosauri originali del film chris
pratt steven spielberg e jeff goldblum
se se se tutti tutti i nostri
praticamente le star che claudio in
particolare ammalasse i corsi e gli ho
detto ma quanto volete questa cosa
invece no ci pagavano loro che pagano
tavano di roba per sfumare questa cosa
ci lamentavamo più eravamo tristi e
sfigati più avevamo presa sulla gente
qui avevamo successo volutamente siamo
arrivati a fare delle nefandezze
allucinante cioè nefandezze noi abbiamo
fatto dei video con nostra mamma che è
malata di slave per fare visualizzazione
della ix che è una cosa terribile quello
era un video e beneficenza che abbiamo
fatto con mamma era un video caricati da
fabbri abbiamo usato mamma in carrozzina
me file ai tantissimi
no è vero quel vita vedranno avrebbe
avuto successo pure che mamma fosse
stata perfetta salute diciamolo fabrizio
natura ti prendi un attimo ripercorre
mentalmente il video non leggo ricorda
benissimo all'inizio alla fine lo
immagini senza mamma
dimmi se funzionerebbero stesso allora
bello pure questo silenzio perché
prendiamo i minuti e in tanto
quanto la notte staremo a cinque minuti
una tragedia
dai pensato no sarebbe stato un video
motion certo non avrebbe funzionato
prima però scusa ma è un video in cui
noi abbiamo avuto l'opportunità di far
vedere una persona in quelle condizioni
di solito si tende a normalizzare cose
assurde cosa da ricchi non si vede mai
la realtà di tutti i giorni
e nostra madre è riuscita a dire una
persona che guardava quel video guarda
io sto vivendo la tua stessa situazione
la sto vivendo in questo modo in un modo
positivo in un modo abbiamo fatto dai
con diamanti laico mamma in carrozzina
però scusa questa è una cosa che fai
anche questa mia ducos col fatto che c'è
la sindrome di tourette la sindrome di
tourette culo così sempre sta cosa ma
magari i fabbri ma magari non ce l'ho
abbastanza la sindrome di tourette non
non funziona non fa ridere e non sono
invece non sono a quei livelli tipo
quello che dice improvvisamente le
parolacce la suora che bestemmia
amarissima liberissimo sorgenti ceo miti
troppo non sono ancora quelli veri non
ci può arrivare qui magari fa mi sto
lavorando io io so solo sa solo qualche
tic che ciò gli occhi strabuzzo gli
occhi naso un po tiro su e giù tipo
cocainomani oppure batte i denti la
mandibola pure un pochino il collo
scrozzo il collo faccio degli scatti
indietro con la testa solo la pelle
spalle le spalle faccio mai rischio
anche di farmaci insomma
cerco cerco anche di comprimere tutti i
muscoli l'addome dopo ogni tanto dove
tutti ma la gamba ma quando fanno
scattino c'è poco da gamba scoppio fa
sentire la croce tutte le dita tutte le
dita il piede lo faccio tipo ballerino
punta così ora c'è questa cosa che rompo
il bicchiere di cristallo se ci va bene
una cosa lieve
non mi sono ancora ma come diceva la
great della turetta anche qui si è
infilato alle spalle bello si si non era
anche previsto commesso adesso invece
così si può arrivare piano piano ma non
c'è io adesso se avessi quel livello di
turetta io potrei che ne so il ragazzo
la idiota che i viola potrebbe risultare
la macchina in primavera è una pratica
bambinetta non si offende perché io la
tourette ha capito io posso facemmo
cretino ott un po troppo usa ce vò un
cafone ma che cavolo mi ha detto idiota
io natura tu non puoi che ora è la
durezza
tu sei un omosessuale può insultare che
no anche se in scena c'è la lobby dei
che non si fosse un uomo ti puoi fare ma
non si può ma non è maturo per fare con
lei ma non ho niente da dire contro i
gay mio marito è gay cosa vuoi e
introvabili ma c'è da grandi poteri
derivano grandi responsabilità tu vuoi
insultare chi possa di eventi realmente
niente
no niente tu c'è qualcosa da dire contro
i gay
contro i gay che civile
che c'entra gli unicorni non esistono
dai non si offenda la persona combinare
niente non c'è niente contro chi è
contro che sembra una colpa non so
niente non ho capito tu piuttosto tu sei
vegano la tu vuoi insulta i vegani dai
sparare sulla croce rossa fabbrini ma
che dici già sono sfigati ma come diceva
sveglia non è che se uno fa una battuta
contro i piani di inopportuno ho fatto
una battuta contro legati ai visti
quelli che fanno le battute contro
italiani che ci hanno mai sentito le
battute che fanno e non ho mai sentire
allora hanno un repertorio vastissimo
viva la più gettonata è la sede chiaro
ti piacciono ancora il ragazzo ma è una
frase che c'entra niente 100 ragazzi
sento niente però va per la maggiore
belli non se ne andò ai comitati sentito
che ha detto si è pure che ne sono altra
cosa e tu style il solare mi sto
mangiando la mia insalatina cavoli miei
arriva velo guarda che ieri altri
soffrono soffre una effettiva ma non lo
so ma non mi faccio fare la morale da
uno e se mangiato una mucca un porco con
cavani
che cosa rispondi quando ti fanno queste
cose fondo previsto la fiction sorriso
di circostanza faccio finta della
73esima volta che senti la stessa
battuta e basta minutino magnani a
cicoria caccia se proprio insistono mi
gioco la carta jolly c'è
un'arma segreta è di minimo sessuale
strette e se siamo tra pochi quadra io
praticamente lo guardo negli occhi
gli dico amico mio a me mi piaceva
patata atte a far ciccio è una cosa ma
la frase terribile una cosa terribile
terribile
che però in quel momento ti devi settare
sul suo livello e cerebrale intelletti
c'è la comunicazione il filo e onde luce
della coscienza deve essere bello quindi
tutti i sette su quello gli stand di
liste zitti mugen yara le gambe
terribile per la campania vale niente
libera terribile bello ma stand di così
perché lui in primis e dovremmo sapere
quanto è importante settarsi sul proprio
target di riferimento non c'è noi per
esempio qui non c'entriamo niente
no fa niente non stiamo facendo una
figura barbina sì certo siamo un po
fuori luogo io l'avevo detto comunque
che era meglio che cosa che abbiamo
fatto c'eravamo la sagra degli
strigliozzi la parola cavedago un valore
capita ad un valore ormai conosciamo a
memoria se appena anno cambiamo e le
facciamo anche un upgrade facciamo anche
una grade nun una volta tanto no scusami
è tutto il nostro target da sagra destro
ragazzo vabbè ok però se per un'altra e
vedendo quei discorsi come quelli che mi
dicono a fondo lo fa del film al cinema
una cifra non è un upgrade perché perché
perché scusa cioè non è che se tu
immagine della gente è abituato a vedere
i nostri video è sulla tazza del
gabinetto e rambo di un ad efficacia e
lo si vede non è l'amara verità di ogni
pagina di questi che escono di casa o il
freddo il caldo il traffico c'è il carro
parcheggio arrivano al cinema con quei
15 euro del biglietto ormai costano
quanto loro stessi del cinema è stato
produrre di noi che diciamo cagate però
su questo d'accordissimo io non sto
dicendo che la gray del cinema sto
dicendo che l'upgrade è riuscire a
staccarsi dalla sicurezza di un trend e
far cambiare parere alle persone
riuscire a farli a fargli cambiare idea
rispetto a qualcosa no che cosa abbiamo
fatto cambiare beh noi abbiamo l'abbiamo
detto tante cose innovative per esempio
noi siamo i più sono stati precursori
noi siamo stati i primi ad avere avuto
il coraggio di dire che la musica il di
fa schifo
scusami noi noi tramite il nostro
linguaggio comico possiamo possiamo
riuscire a cambiare il mondo non è il
paese in cui la bella città quartiere
portinaio da qualche parte deve iniziare
però che noi potremmo riuscire tramite
il nostro linguaggio ad essere come come
i grandi comici con un charlie chaplin
che tramite un film comico è riuscito a
dare una stoccata la politica
internazionale paolo villaggio ha creato
una maschera per criticare la grassa
dirigente italiana eduardo de filippo
che ha cambiato il linguaggio della
commedia all'italiana benigni ci ha
infuso una cultura allucinante
ammazzandosi la verità casa sua
comico afghano che tramite una risata
voleva cambiare il proprio paese e
tramite quella stessa risata e facendo
ridere è morto tra le mani dei talebani
cretino cretino
abbiamo questa è una cosa seria la
volontà ma perché
la fuoriuscita di una cosa seria da
figuraccia
[Applauso]
[Musica]